soyons clairs dans la guerre économique
tous les coups sont permis
la stratégie de conquête de marchés à
l'exportation s'appuie sur une politique
offensive de pillages deux fleurons du
secteur stratégique
le succès passe toujours par la
connaissance parfaite de son adversaire
en jouant sur quatre critères clés
l'argent l'idéologie légaux et la
compromission
ce phénomène il est mondial on le
retrouve partout
c'est pourquoi on est frappé par la
naïveté des personnels et de
l'encadrement à ce type de pratiques il
existe sur la planète
beaucoup d'acteurs chez keek et sans
aucune hésitation ni morale la fin
justifie les
[Musique]
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer dans une
heure depuis beyrouth au terme de sa
visite au liban
à peine un mois après la double
explosion qui a ravagé une partie de la
capitale
le chef de l'état français a proposé une
conférence de soutien en octobre à paris
dans l'après midi il avait rencontré les
principaux responsables politiques
cette visite intervient dans un contexte
tendu plusieurs manifestions
manifestations ont eu lieu cet après
midi à beyrouth pour protester contre la
nomination du premier ministre
12 millions et demi d l'avons repris le
chemin de l'école ce matin une première
journée qui s'est déroulée dans le
contexte particulier de la crise
sanitaire liée aux coronavirus masque
gel hydroalcoolique distanciation
sociale au sein des établissements
scolaires à des mesures ont été prises
pour éviter une seconde vague rt france
est allé recueillir des témoignages de
parents venus récupérer leurs enfants à
la sortie d'une école parisienne
[Musique]
donald trump en visite aujourd'hui à
kenosha dans le wisconsin le président
américain vient constater les dégâts
engendrés par les émeutes à la suite de
l' affaire jack up blake
pendant ce temps son rival joe biden
était tiers en meeting à pittsburgh en
pennsylvanie
il accuse notamment donald trump
d'attiser les violences et les divisions
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 20h heure de paris
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur rt france
direction le liban où le président
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer de 10
d'ici une heure maintenant il est arrivé
hier soir un agenda bien chargé pour le
président français a dès ce matin il est
allé sur les lieux du drame vers le port
de beyrouth
cet après midi le président de la
république a rencontré les responsables
politiques libanais dont le président
michel aoun et le nouveau premier
ministre fraîchement élu mustapha adib
le chef de l'état a prévenu les
dirigeants libanais qu'il s'exposerait à
des sanctions s'il ne parvenait pas à
tracer dans les trois mois un nouveau
cap pour un pays qui traverse sa pire
crise de son côté emmanuel macron a
proposé d'accueillir une conférence de
soutien à paris à il a déjà prévu de
revenir au liban en décembre prochain
écoutez moi je suis prêt pour dorer au
four
me forster une conférence internationale
de soutien des nations unies l
accueillir à la parole et à ce que là on
est sous la barre de de l'expression de
demander tu prendras écrit frappe
et si sous une coordination nations
unies très préfère conduisent à nouveau
demander un soutien un peu les
différents états et en marge de la venue
d' emmanuel macron à la colère des
libanais étaient toujours présentes
plusieurs rassemblements étaient prévus
dont la 1 lancée sous le slogan de la
colère du grand liban à l'occasion du
centenaire de la proclamation de l'état
du grand liban c'était le 1er septembre
1920 et vous allez le voir sur ces
images
ils étaient plusieurs centaines à
manifester cet après midi dans la
capitale hier même scène devant l'entrée
du port de beyrouth les manifestants
demandent une enquête transparente sur
la catastrophe du 4 août dernier et
l'abandon du système politique
multiconfessionnel ils dénoncent
également la corruption qui entraîne la
chute du pays
certains protestent aussi contre la
nouvelle nomination au poste de premier
ministre
de mustapha a dit blanc
et pour en parler nous sommes avec fouad
abou nader hommes politiques libanais
fondateur du front de la liberté liberté
pardon bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
alors on attend 1 d'ici une heure
maintenant une parole du président
emmanuel macron au terme de sa visite
une prise de parole initialement prévue
à 18h30
le président français continuent
d'échanger avec des responsables
libanais au fond qu'est-ce que vous
attendez de sa prise de parole
à l'issue de cette visite au liban est
premièrement déjà le fait qu'ils soient
revenus
c'est une vraiment une grande bouffée
d'oxygène pour ces libanais qui sont
très meurtrie et depuis le 17 octobre
2019 nous sommes sans passer par une
crise où le pays est arrivé presque à la
banqueroute total tout à fait et ensuite
nous avons tout notre argent gâté
bloqués dans l'est la banque centrale
est ensuite les locaux vides et
maintenant l'explosion de beyrouth donc
avoir un président comme le président de
la france qui vient de visiter ce pays
et qui parle avec les gens qui descendra
la rue qui salue les gens ce qu aucun
responsable libanais n'a fait finalement
c'est il a fallu que ce soit le
plaisance fort c'est qu'il y a donc déjà
ça en lui même ça a beaucoup
d'importance pour les libérer mais pour
autant pas pardonné mois certains
libanais se sont néanmoins dits déçus de
cette deuxième visite du président
comment vous me comprenez je crois que
ça encore tôt pour ces libanais je crois
il ya des gens qui sont de mauvaise foi
dans tous les cas qu'ils vont dire
n'importe quoi
dans tous les cas c'est encore tôt il
faut attendre un peu ce qu'il va dire ce
soir ce qu'il va annoncer et il va les
humer bien sûr la visite qu'il a fait
ici
mais déjà on a vu ce qu'il a fait à la
fois passé il a fait juste et tout de
suite et une visioconférence avec les
responsables des grands pays et dans ce
monde il a ok il a ramené une petite
somme d'argent parce que les quelques
centaines de millions qu'il a ramené
bien sûr ne peuvent pas faire grand
chose pour lui les membres déjà c'est un
grand geste un grand geste envers les
libanais ensuite il s'est engagé dans
plusieurs choses
la première il a lui-même téléphoné au
président ben ali pour l'inciter à faire
les les consultations avec les députés
pour justement nommé un premier ministre
je crois que il a influencé et
l'atmosphère au liban et c'est ce qui a
fait qu'aujourd'hui nous avons un
premier ministre qui a été nommé bon il
a été nommé par les mêmes gens qui ont
nommé le premier ni ce qui inquiétait
avant et ensuite il ya eu juste pour la
petite anecdote vous savez hadid et dia
celui qui était avant sa plaie dia donc
les gens quiconque y joue un peu au
scrabble ont su vous interverti c'est un
tout petit peu les lettres vous avez le
mail est nos différents voilà maintenant
nous avons nous tort a dit et nous
savons pertinemment que les mêmes
parties le ramener mais cette fois ci
monsieur a dit viens avec une couverture
sunnite qui est importante
et deuxièmement une en en principe une
couverture internationale et arabe
ce que monsieur dia n'avait pas avant
lui ce matin pour revenir aux paroles du
président emmanuel macron il s'est dit
prêt à réorganiser une conférence de
soutien international notamment avec les
états unis est ce que c'est une bonne
idée
oui bien sûr que c'était une bonne idée
bien sûr et je crois qu'avec un arbitre
comme le plaisir de re max aussi ceci
pour les données beaucoup plus de 2 2
résultat bien sûr et quelles sont les
relations entre le liban et les usa
aujourd'hui
ben ça va mal parce que les usa
considèrent que le président et le le
parlement aussi la majorité du parlement
son trophée ce volant avec un
gouvernement qui est très proche donc si
vous voulez nous avons maintenant une
mauvaise presse sur états unis mais ce
qui est bien c'est que avec le président
macro mois il a joué justement comme je
vous ai dit la bid
il a engagé l'union européen il a parlé
avec l'arabie saoudite des airs de
clients
donc c'est un monsieur qui est entrain
de d'aplanir les difficultés en train
d'enlever les mines
pour permettre à ce pays de se redresser
alors le président français manuel
macron a appelé à la mise en place d'un
gouvernement de mission au plus vite je
le cite pour prendre de vraies réformes
susceptibles de satisfaire les libanais
aujourd'hui de quelle réforme a besoin
le liban dans l'urgence a avant tout il
faut arrêter la dégradation économique
du pays déjà ça au moins qu'on arrête
pour qu'on puisse un peu réfléchir la
deuxième chose il faut prendre en
considération que nous avons eu une
énorme explosion qui a détruit au moins
le quart de beyrouth surtout le quartier
chrétien de beyrouth qu'il faut
absolument le construire et rénover les
maisons pour amener les gens chez eux
donc ça c'est inné np une priorité
deuxièmement il faut s'adresser aux
problèmes économiques de la banqueroute
du pays
donc il faut engager le plus vite
possible les discussions avec le fonds
monétaire international et et
troisièmement il faut préparer ensuite
ça va avec le front monétaire
international et beaucoup de deux choses
qui doit venir et de la banque centrale
du liban avec un audit avec essayer de
rapatrier l'argent qui a été volé et qui
a été transféré en dehors du liban et
ses talents je veux pas rentrer dans
tous ses détails et la troisième chose
il faut aller vers le volet les
changements c'est à dire un le côté
légal
les tribunaux les lois etc mais il faut
que vraiment qu'on ait une justice qui
soit vraiment équitable et juste
et ensuite il faut aller arranger les
choses de la vie de tous les jours des
idées et des libanais que ce soit
l'électricité savez que depuis 30 ans
nous n'avons pas d'électricité
24 h/24 au liban non l'homme nous
n'avons pas un bon ramassage et du
traitement des ordures
imaginez un peu une année encore avec
ses responsables politiques qui ont
vraiment vraiment vidé le pays
toute la substance merci beaucoup fouad
abou nader d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que nous
un homme politique libanais fondateur du
front de la liberté près de 12 millions
et demi d'élèves ont donc fait leur
rentrée ce mardi en france après
plusieurs mois de confinement suivi des
vacances scolaires les élèves ont
retrouvé les bancs de l'école
des retrouvailles particulières avec
leurs enseignants alors que le pays
enregistre plus de 3000 nouveaux cas de
contamination et 29 décès en 24 heures
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer air s'est voulu rassurant il a
estimé que cette rentrée était bien
préparé notre reporter katia pique nique
est allé prendre la température à la
sortie d'un établissement scolaire assez
dans le thé dans le 20e arrondissement
de paris l'ambiance était à la confiance
aujourd'hui devant les écoles il faut
dire que juste après le confinement les
protocoles tâtonner mais aujourd'hui
après plusieurs mois de recul
tout semble bien mise en place par
exemple les parents d'élèves attendent à
l'extérieur de l'établissement ils ne
peuvent plus entrer on leur apporte les
enfants pour éviter la circulation du
virus alors peut-on parler de rentrée
presque normal comme l'a dit le premier
ministre jean castex je n'irai pas
jusque là car des règles viennent un peu
compliqué cette rentrée par exemple le
port du masque est obligatoire pour tous
les élèves à partir de 11 ans donc au
collège port du masque obligatoire dans
les salles de classe également en salle
de récréation et port du masque
obligatoire également pour les
enseignants les professeurs les maîtres
d'école à partir de la maternelle les
autres gestes à appliquer sont les
gestes barrières par exemple les enfants
sont invités à se désinfecter les mains
dès l'entrée à l'école et puis
évidemment la distanciation social tout
cela est expliqué dans l'établissement
je vous propose d'écouter certains
parents concernant leur réaction face à
cette rentrée j'ai trouvé que c'était
plutôt bien organisé que les gestes
barrières étaient respectées et voilà la
direction de l'école c'est plutôt bien
préparés à cette rentrée assez
particulière on avait le droit de
rentrer dans l'école mais les enfants
devaient se laver les mains
pénétrez effectivement il fallait porter
des masques pour les parents voilà
c'était plutôt bien cadré bien organisée
après il est compliqué pour des enfants
d'aller au delà je veux dire les
protocoles trop strict ne pourront pas
être appliquée pour nous ça a été ça a
été ça dans le sens où on connaissait
déjà les consignes vu que c'était
diffusé à la télé un peu partout un peu
partout mais c'est vrai qu'à l'école
ils nous ont pas rappeler les consignes
à nous mais je pense qu aux enfants ils
ont dû le faire peuvent monter leurs
attaques les consignes là ils ont quand
même eu plus de deux mois pour roder la
chose et l'expérience en fête de l'avent
de l'avant vacances donc là je pense que
ça devrait aller
alors que se passera-t-il en cas de
contamination d'un élève ou d'un
professeur et bien des fermetures de
classes ciblées pourront être réalisés
et dans ce cas le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a expliqué
qu'un congé parental pourrait être
accordé pour garder les enfants qui
n'auraient plus classe voilà ce qu'on
peut retenir de cette rentrée pas comme
les autres sachant que le protocole
pourra être adapté au fil de l'épidémie
toujours en france à partir de demain et
jusqu'au 10 novembre devant la cour
d'assises spéciale de paris se tiendra
le procès intégralement filmé et des
attentes est charlie hebdo de montrouge
et de l'hyper cacher en janvier 2015 14
personnes vont être jugées
ce drame avait fait 17 morts et
plusieurs blessés en trois jours
ces attentats ont marqué les esprits au
delà des frontières
près de 200 parties civiles une centaine
d'avocats et 50 jours d'audience jean
michel faubert et de débuter la
république en marge de seine et marne
dirigeait à l'époque le raid au moment
des attentats et ils restent très
marqués par la mission que le premier
ministre de l'époque bernard cazeneuve
lui avait confié en janvier 2015 le jour
de la tacc de l'hyper cacher un
témoignage il est dit écoutez le
sentiment que j'en garde au plus profond
de moi c'est un sur cette affaire-là
d'abord
un énorme pour pour le chef du
dispositif que j'étais un énorme
problème une énorme équation à plusieurs
inconnues à résoudre pour pouvoir à la
fois libéré l'ensemble des des otages
qui avait été pris à la porte de
vincennes
il y en avait 26 et en même temps en
ayant le moins de dégâts possibles parmi
par lui mais trou parmi les gens que je
commandais donc c'est une
c'est une équation psychologiquement
difficile techniquement pas facile non
plus et opérationnellement très
compliqué aussi
on a on peut dire que dans cette
opération là on a libéré tous les otages
et ça pour le coup pour tous les gens
qui étaient là pour tous les gens du
raid pour tous les gens de la berri mais
tous les policiers qui étaient là et les
gens du lait même les hommes politiques
qui à l'époque était au et était aux
affaires
c'est une énorme fierté que d'avoir tous
ensemble sauver ses 26 et puis en marge
de ce procès historique et charlie hebdo
a décidé de re publié les caricatures du
prophète mahomet qui en avait fait la
cible des terroristes on ne se couchera
jamais on ne renoncera jamais justifie
riis le directeur de l'hebdomadaire
satirique à nouveau numéro qui sera
disponible demain avec pour titre tout
ça pour ça
en tunisie pour la troisième fois en un
an les députés sont amenés à participer
à un vote de confiance pour un nouveau
gouvernement vote à suspense
signe de l'instabilité du à la
fragmentation des voix au sein du
parlement élu en octobre dernier afin de
pouvoir remplacer l'équipe des liesses
fakfak le gouvernement du nouveau
premier ministre désigné
hichem mais chichi doit obtenir 109 voix
sur 217 elle s'il n'obtient pas ce vote
de confiance le président kaïs sayed
devra convoquer des élections
législatives anticipées dans le premier
ministre hichem mais chichi bien
conscient des difficultés économiques du
pays espèrent la confiance des députés
et j'ai choisi de parler de cette
situation économique difficile qui
présente des indicateurs dangereux non
pas pour imputer la responsabilité à
aucun parti
mais pour en tirer les leçons et les
résultats avec courage et pour alerter
sur la nécessité de passer au travail
audacieux pour sauver notre pays
maintenant et sans attendre la formation
de ce gouvernement intervient dans une
situation caractérisée par l'instabilité
politique
dix mois après l'organisation des
élections législatives le gouvernement
se présente pour avoir votre confiance
dans un moment où la patience du peuple
tunisien a atteint ses limites et pour
ryan chaibi président de l'association
pour la promotion de la coopération et
de l'amitié entre la france et la
tunisie
le scénario le plus probable est un vote
de confiance en faveur du premier
ministre désigné coûté six films et
chichi n'obtient pas la confiance du du
gouvernement alors c'est assez assez
paradoxal mais on va tomber dans un vide
constitutionnel parce que la
constitution ne prévoit pas de cas de
figure en cas de non renouvellement en
tout cas de non confiance du de la part
de l'assemblée des représentants du
peuple donc il ya deux cas de figure ou
bien le gouvernement michy passe et
c'est très bien pour la tunisie et je le
souhaite
ou bien il n'obtient pas la confiance et
à ce moment là on va continuer avec un
gouvernement d'expédition des affaires
courantes dirigé par ilyas faire faire
en attendant une éventuelle décision de
la part du chef de l'état de dissoudre
le parlement parce que dans ce cas de
figure le président de la république
peut dissoudre mais il en est pas obligé
donc c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à on va
dire dans un espèce de vide et nabro bio
constitutionnel mais je ne pense pas
qu'on en arrivera là parce que tout
laisse à penser que hichem les chichis
obtiendra la confiance du parlement
donald trump attendu à kanyosha dans le
wisconsin une visite sous tension pour
le président américain alors que
l'émotion est toujours vive aux états
unis depuis qu'un policier a tiré à sept
reprises sur un homme noir le 23 août
dernier
retour sur les faits avec quentin
mauclair neuf jours après le drame qui a
vu jacob black devenir paralysé à vie
après avoir été touché dans le dos par
cette balle tirée par un policier
donald trump doit se rendre ce mardi à
qeynos chat théâtre de l'arrestation
violente depuis ce tragique événement
les manifestations se multiplient dans
tout le pays
une personne a ainsi été tué à portland
ce week-end lors de heurts entre
manifestants anti raciste et partisan de
donald trump pour ne pas attiser les
tensions
le maire de kenosha émis le voeu que le
président américain reporte sa visite
nous avons toujours de la place pour que
les présidents viennent nous rendre
visite et que les candidats viennent
nous rendre visite
c'est le processus habituel et c'est
quelque chose que nous apprécierons mais
nous avons le sentiment que le moment
choisi n'est pas le bon et nous lui
avons donc demandé de faire cette visite
à un autre moment
je pense qu'en ce moment kenosha a
besoin de paix besoin de guérir et
besoin que l'on nous laisse faire les
bons tuyaux
cette demande a été rejetée par le
locataire de la maison blanche qui a
annoncé rendre visite aux responsables
de la police locale
lors de sa dernière conférence de presse
ce nodule trump a ajouté qu'il n'a pas
prévu de rencontrer la famille de jacob
black ce mardi à neuf semaines de
l'élection présidentielle
joe biden a de son côté accusé donald
trump d'être responsables des violences
qui agitent le pays
le président a depuis longtemps
abandonné toutes qualités morales comme
dit
les gens de ce pays il ne peut pas
arrêter la violence car pendant des
années la entretenu vous savez ils
pensent peut-être que déblatérer les
mots loi et ordre ce alors en forme et
son incapacité à appeler ses propres
partisans à arrêter de se comporter
comme une milice armée à travers le pays
vous montre à quel point il est faible
des accusations que le président
américain réfute catégoriquement les
émeutiers et joe biden sont du même côté
ils sont tous les deux dans le camp de
la gauche radicale
c'est tellement évident tant que cela ne
sera pas à neutraliser
vous ne serez jamais en sécurité dans
les endroits dirigé par les démocrates
depuis des mois joe biden a apporté son
soutien moral et du réconfort aux
vandales en répétant les mensonge
monstrueux selon lesquelles il
s'agissait de manifestations pacifiques
ce n'était pas des manifestations
pacifiques la visite de donald trump
pourrait donc être mouvementé l'émotion
est encore dans tous les esprits
ce déplacement du chef d'état américain
pourrait bien jeter de l'huile sur le
feu
nouvelle journée de manifestation des
étudiants biélorusse aujourd'hui à minsk
ils étaient des centaines en avoir
profité de la rentrée scolaire et
universitaire pour défiler dans les rues
de la capitale à la jeunesse glorieuse
constitue un des piliers de la
mobilisation contre alexandre
loukachenko tous contestent sa
réélection au poste de président le 9
août dernier
aujourd'hui les forces de l'ordre ont
interpellé une dizaine d'étudiantes
tentaient de former une chaîne humaine
au centre de la capitale de l'ancienne
république soviétique alexandre
loukachenko me lui sur la liste noire
des pays baltes pour ces pays il s'agit
de sanctionner le président biélorusse
pour fraude électorale présumée à la
suite de sa réélection le 9 août dernier
à mais aussi pour la répression des
manifestants de l'opposition le
président bio le russe qui semble
vouloir apaiser les tensions a évoqué
hier un référendum constitutionnel
énigmes cachent des sanctions qui
ciblent directement le président
biélorusse 29 hauts fonctionnaires sont
également inscrits sur ces listes noires
ils font partie de la commission
électorale deux ministères mais aussi
des forces de l'ordre nous envoyons le
message que nous devons faire davantage
que simplement publier des déclarations
nous devons également prendre des
mesures concrètes
nous nous attaquons aux violations des
droits de l'homme en biélorussie avec le
plus grand sérieux des sanctions
qualifié de pression contre productive
par la diplomatie biélorusse qui a
promis une réponse adéquate aux pays
baltes l'histoire de notre état
indépendant confirme clairement que
toute tentative d'exercer une pression
sur la biélorussie en imposant des
sanctions ne fait que produire l'effet
inverse recherché par ses auteurs nous
avons déjà dit que la biélorussie serait
obligé de répondre de manière adéquate
aux auteurs de ces initiatives et nous
le ferons et nous allons attendre le
moment le bon sens prévaudra dans les
esprits de nos partenaires l'union
européenne envisage également
d'interdire d'entrée sur son territoire
une vingtaine de fonctionnaires
biélorusses et de geler leurs avoirs
mais parmi les 27 pays de l'ue eux
certains craignent que des sanctions
directes contre alexandre loukachenko
n'anéantisse la possibilité
médiation entre les autorités et
l'opposition
le président biélorusse qui de son côté
semble vouloir apaiser les tensions
il a évoqué l'idée d'un référendum
constitutionnel sur une réforme
judiciaire
malgré le fait que nous ayons un système
quelque peu autoritaire pour organiser
la vie publique
le président protège et défend néanmoins
les tribunaux mais c'est un aspect
personnel et nous devons nous assurer
que le système fonctionne sans être liés
aux individus par conséquent je pense
que dans la nouvelle constitution nous
refléteront de manière adéquate le
système d'organisation de nos tribunaux
un référendum dont alexandre loukachenko
n'a précisé ni les modalités ni une date
potentielle mais qu'il avait déjà
évoquée dans le passé moscou l'avait
d'ailleurs qualifié de pistes
prometteuses pour sortir de la crise
depuis trois semaines la contestation
continue de gronder dans les bouts de
minsk dimanche l'opposition a rassemblé
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
dans la capitale et sur ce dossier mais
dernières nouvelles de moscou avec notre
correspondant antoine clermont
la russie est en elle même la cible de
sanctions de la part des états unis ou
encore de l'union européenne
elle s'est montrée plutôt solidaire
envers son voisin biélorusse on l'a
entendu les trois pays baltes dont la
lituanie qui accueille à l'heure
actuelle l'opposante biélorusse 7 la
nature and hove kaya ont déclaré persona
non grata alexandre loukachenko mais
aussi 29 autres hauts responsables
politiques espèrent bien entraîné dans
son sillage le reste de l'union
européenne une décision qu'a dénoncé
sergueï lavrov le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères a en outre rappelé
la position de la russie sur le sujet à
savoir que personne ne vienne s'immiscer
dans les affaires intérieures de la
biélorussie écouter le voisin bio russe
traverse actuellement des moments
difficiles nous avons très clairement
exprimé notre position et le président
poutine en a parlé de manière franche
nous allons nous baser sur le droit
international ainsi que sur les
obligations qui existe entre la russie
et la république de biélorussie
bien sûr nous souhaitons que les
biélorusses et la possibilité de
résoudre eux mêmes leur propre
m sans aucune ingérence extérieure et
nous voyons la tentation qui existe
parmi de nombreux états occidentaux mais
aussi dans l'ukraine voisine où des pays
très éloignée située de l'autre côté de
l'océan comme les états unis le canada
d'imposer certaines approches face à la
situation actuelle en république de
biélorussie s'est pas trop de le
président biélorusse réagi à ces
approches
nous considérons qu'il n'y a aucun
besoin d'imposer une médiation intrusive
le président biélorusse a proposé une
réforme constitutionnelle
à mon avis et selon nos analyses général
c'est un cadre dans lequel ni est tout à
fait possible d'organiser un dialogue
avec la société civile afin de débattre
de toutes les questions qui suscitent
l'inquiétude d'une partie des citoyens
biélorusses ou d'une autre et 14 passes
pour l'étape se dit si le nom est normal
ou ce qu elle age sergueï lavrov qui
aura de nouveau l'occasion de s'exprimer
sur le sujet dès demain en effet il
reçoit la visite de son homologue
biélorusse qui viendra ainsi chercher le
soutien de moscou dans cette affaire
mais peut-être aussi des conseils sur
l'organisation d'un référendum
constitutionnel une proposition
d'alexandre loukachenko qui là qu'il a
émises pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière et encore réitérée durant la
journée d'hier mais qui n'a pas encore
rencontré un écho favorable du côté des
manifestants
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes
restez avec nous sur arte france à tout
à l'heure
et
[Musique]